So we've done a ton of deep dives and policy
centric stuff over the last few days.
We did a nearly 20 minute segment on fiscal
and monetary policy yesterday.
We are going to be talking later today about
a good versus a bad clinical trial for a medication.
How randomized clinical trials work.
The importance of placebo.
Placebo.
How vaccinations are developed and researched.
Let's do a brief interlude from that, because
the Trump crazy hasn't stopped and Donald
Trump had a massive eruption.
Eruption?
Careful, that's not using a different word.
He had a huge eruption where he threatened
his own campaign manager with a lawsuit.
What made Trump lose his mind?
It is some of those polls I recently told
you about the fact that Trump is losing to
Joe Biden in a bunch of recent polls.
This includes in the general election.
This includes a couple of polls out of Florida.
One poll out of Texas.
One poll out of North Carolina.
So this was not a good seven days for Donald
Trump.
Last Thursday, Trump wondered aloud about
injecting bleach to treat Corona virus, instantly
going globaly viral and making him yet again
the butt of jokes and a complete and total
laughing stock.
Friday, he bails on a press briefing without
taking a single question, clearly to avoid
questions about those bleach injection statements.
And then he ends up Friday evening on a phone
call with his campaign manager, Brad Parr.
Scale and Trump went off on PA scale for the
bad poll numbers, according to three people
familiar with this phone call.
Trump threatened to sue his own campaign manager.
For what?
It's not exactly clear.
Neither the White House nor the Trump campaign
have put out any comment about these reports.
have denied the report, which tells us a lot
about what we need to know.
One Republican close to the White House said
Trump is angry because he knows he messed
up the briefings.
Apparently, Trump started to become irate
about polling last Wednesday night when his
campaign manager and other advisers sat him
down.
And they said, listen, the polls don't look
good in a lot of these states.
Many of these are important battleground states
that you probably need.
And they confronted him about how his briefings
seem to be hurting him.
Thursday, Trump drops the bleach bomb and
things completely implode again.
Advisers go to Trump and say, you are you
are hurting yourself with these press briefings.
Friday, Trump goes absolutely nuts walking
out of the press briefing room without taking
a single question.
Hours later, getting on the phone with his
campaign manager and threatening to sue the
guy.
So, listen, this is not funny.
It's not been funny for a long time.
Trump is very much unwell.
This is a sick individual.
The Corona virus handling has been a disaster.
We've already shot past the death toll that
Donald Trump preemptively bragged would be
where we end up of 60000.
Now Trump starts talking about 65.
Well, we're going to be there in a few days
and we're gonna blow past that as well.
And we have to worry about.
Can Trump handle this?
Is Trump having another breakdown?
Is he emotionally stable?
We learned a couple of days ago that Trump
is often watching.
This is not a typo. Trump is watching five
to seven hours of TV a day before going to
work around noon or later rage tweeting as
he watches TV.
This is not a president.
This is a petulant child.
Trump has wondered about nuking.
Hurricanes, nuclear weapons on hurricanes.
Trump suggested the US look at buying Greenland.
Trump talked about injecting bleach, hitting
the body with light, as he said, and on and
on and on.
And I get it that there's an element of comic
relief to this when I see this next clip.
I can't help but laugh.
This is video from earlier this week or under
this Dickinson call Logic and SFA.
Fefe Saffa hide.
I get it.
It's hard not to laugh at that, but this is
a perfect storm of bad ideas combined with
incipient arrogance, limited reading ability
and a personality problem, if not a personality
disorder.
And when you look at it in total, there's
really nothing funny about it.
You know Cobb BFE have Saffa hide all of it.
Individually, these things are funny.
I get it and I laugh and we laugh to avoid
crying, quite frankly.
But we're paying a big price for this now.
During the pandemic, and I would truly enjoy
nothing more than seeing Donald Trump absolutely
blown out in the November election.
Trump often falsely claims that he had the
biggest win of any win in 2016.
Remember, he lost the popular vote by nearly
3 million votes.
I want it for the country.
I want Donald Trump absolutely crushed in
November because we need him out.
I don't know that that will happen.
Every single vote must be gained.
Every single vote must be worked for.
But I'm admitting to you guys on a personal
level, I would take great satisfaction in
seeing Donald Trump, the narcissist in chief,
absolutely destroyed in a historic Joe Biden
victory in November.
I would take any victory and we've got to
work hard for every single vote.
But this is a man who is not well.
He is not well.
And every single day we hear something else
about his emotional instability.
He has access to nuclear weapons and he can't
even control himself enough to avoid threatening
his own campaign manager with a lawsuit for
what we don't know because he's losing in
the polls and embarrassing himself on television.
It's ugly.
And we'll have continued coverage of this
on The David Pakman Show Instagram page at
David Pakman show.
Make sure to follow.
We'll take a quick break and
be
right down.